[Music]
hey Dad morning it'll be like it never
happened what's going on
William something's not right with me
tell me the truth there was a crash
you win the kids tied initiate
I brought you back
there is a reason human cloning is
banned any death
we stole millions of dollars worth of
bi9 equipment I hope you're ready to go
to jail
those three subjects are our property I
didn't define every natural law there is
just to lose you again
how could you do this because I love you
[Music]
there's one thing I know about the world
it's not the little things that matter
it's the tiny things do you want a tiny
piece of cheese yes yes Jesus my life my
name is Bella and this is how I met
Lucas see those things I really like you
maybe that's a sign her home supposed to
be don't choose shoes oh don't you shoot
that one was his favorite over the years
we did everything together
girl we chased a squirrel
we went to work we even played a game
called doctor doctor doctor game
everything all right yeah life with
Lucas was the best but when he wasn't
around I missed him so much
that squirrel again squirrel squirrel
squirrel
[Music]
it looks like she needs help I can tell
where the change I was very far from
home but I knew Lucas was waiting for me
and I had to go and find him
when I'm why
even better than a tiny piece of cheese
we all face things that are hard the
only thing that gets us through it are
the special people in our lives and I
was never going to stop searching until
I found mine
[Music]
that dog saved his life
[Music]
hi eggs you're gonna be late okay you
okay yeah
thanks mom a land is only as good as its
leaders somebody help me hey leave him
alone
a true king is brave and noble don't be
a hero
on the King around here you have more
battles yet to fight
now you must choose what you stand for
Paris school she was found written in
the guard put it into google translate
it means sort of partner what if you're
the only person who could have pulled
that sort out what if it's Excalibur ah
[Music]
finally follow me
I am Merlin thought mine was supposed to
be in a way an ingenious disguise do you
think in four days the dark sorcerer
Morgana will take over the world it's
ridiculous there's your sore back and
good luck with everything
Laura King Alexander the sword chose you
while we help you because you're the
strongest people I know you're my
Knights
and this is the round table quick better
slaps oh my god you're such a nerd this
is this
like in every story we have a right Luke
Skywalker Harry Potter something amazing
happens they find out they descended
from magical families one don't freak
out okay
this is the best
oh hey the once and future king
please don't it's embarrassing
what did you drive Mario Kart
[Music]
you need to prove you're looking for
work
I've been looking trust me three
signatures by tomorrow or you can tell
it to the judge
tell me about a time when you worked
hard to solve a problem this morning
getting up we're gonna find you someone
you like
let me be your arms and your legs I love
all right
penthouse you need to wait your turn
relax it's not a holdup just sign this
one please how would I sign it
I don't know slowly don't your arms work
they don't even move your mouth as can
use I need assistance
mrs. appe hell yeah you are not
qualified for this position have you
change your catheter nah pinch the head
insert thing I can't feel it oh well I
can't you wanna feed your soul listen to
it scoop thank thank think about what
you're trying to do to me it's amazing
it sounds just like yeah it's uncanny
he was rich is jay-z no Richard
which caused us all of these to the
right oh yeah they're not practical
exactly
you can have any girl you want for box
later on Botox I'll be brothers to each
other you can't move your body she can't
move her face I specifically said
nothing for my birthday I'm sorry you
gotta have a surprise party in a huge
mansion someone's got real problems
I'm fighting to see my son and whose
fault is it is it yours or is the world
how to get you mad I'm gonna break this
big-ass bottle one Dell made a mess
[Music]
relax
[Music]
you know how flemeth like to say
everybody knows everything it would be
fine if the truth was it nobody knows
anything
Helen live in Atlanta that feels like
we've all being here forever
where's this just a little scratch
please don't kill that man know what I
will give you ten million dollars just
drop my husband in the ocean for the
sharks is right and wrong heaven in hell
some weird stuff going on right now this
old man's a part of it but nobody knows
it
okay Johnny wants a juice you don't
it's funny huh
where in the world are we
[Music]
so happy adjourn here after my parents
died and I didn't really think I was
gonna be able to come back to Tijuana
but you always made me feel like family
you are my family
[Music]
[Music]
yeah Merrick Los Angeles I just want to
find my friend I need you to do a favor
for me first
you mess around and I'll kill you both
the car real close to the curb
you see you have to believe me they made
me do it the building that you blew up
the DEA safe house you know how long you
go away for unless you help us get Nino
Esparza
see the
forget your friends who's coming to see
you whether or not you survive
entirely up to you
learn how to use one of these
voila bullet balleseros everything ever
since you showed up the police been one
step ahead
you better do what you need to do so you
know there's a mole in his operation I
have a plan I'm gonna come back
I'm not giving up on my family La Bella
in the end
the bullet that was everything
[Music]
little box on the hillside little boxes
made of ticky tacky little boxes on the
design and they all look just the same
[Music]
you want to control your life but life
isn't a science experiment you can't
contain your world forever try doing one
thing that scares you over break okay
yeah
this serves as an entry voucher for me
most escape rooms be the first to escape
our most immersive room yet and win a
million dollars so uh when does the game
start
I think this is the escape room we
should look for clues what are we
looking for here anything that looks
like a puzzle or code it looks like an
oven dial
well that's creepy as hell 450
talk about a person what's wrong with
you that was real Wow
dumb question are we outside soon we get
this figured out soon we'll get the hell
out of here
little box
watching us they know everything's over
leak everything about us this is my
hospital bed me too they made these
rooms for us I've never seen things that
weren't there before
that's why they chose us and they all
look
[Music]
you